-Our next guest is a very funny
comedian you know from shows
such as "The Black Lady
Sketch Show"
and "Miracle Workers."
Her hit show "Abbott Elementary"
airs Tuesday nights on ABC.
Let's take a look.
-Recess is almost over.
-School is almost over.
-Okay, maybe if you guys
weren't double-handed.
Maybe it's not me.
Maybe it's you.
Alright, here we go.
Jacob, that was my turn.
-♪ Down by the river
where the Green grass grows ♪
♪ There sat Janine,
sweet as a rose ♪
♪ Along came Jacob,
do a double-Dutch. ♪
♪ Janine's on the sidelines. ♪
♪ Jealous much? ♪
-Please welcome back
to the show,
our friend Quinta Brunson,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, Quinta!
How you doing?
-Thank you for having me.
-It is so lovely to have you.
The first time you were on the
show with via Zoom,
and now we have you
in New York City.
Are you happy to be back
in New York?
-Mm-hmm.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-It's so -- I know I've been
in New York before,
but I've been in L.A.
for 10 years now.
-Yeah.
-And it's just --
there's trash everywhere
in New York.
I just saw the prettiest lady
walk by a pile of trash,
and I was just like,
"What a way to live.
What a way to live."
[ Laughter ]
Beautiful New York, yes.
-We have a very wide range
of experiences here.
-You do. Yes, beautiful.
it's very nice.
I'm trying not to --
Come on, I just got my show.
I don't want New Yorkers
to get mad.
-Yeah, exactly.
It's a very big chunk of people
that watch television.
You have a hit TV show --
a thing that is so hard to do,
especially a network comedy.
It must be thrilling to have
come up with this idea
for a show and have people
respond to it.
-It is. First of all,
it's kind of incredible,
because I'm asking people
to tune in at a time
on a Tuesday night, and people
are actually tuning in to watch.
And so, I have to say thank
you to people for doing that.
It matters. It really matters.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And now you have people like
Scott over here
who want parts in the show.
-Well, I support black
excellence, so...
-That's very nice to hear.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wait, you told him that?
I telling him that now.
No, but that's so funny.
I did not know that.
-Well, me and Tyler have been
talking about it.
We'll talk about it.
We can have dinner.
-Grabbing dinner after this.
-That was very -- You're like,
"we'll talk later."
That's very L.A.
-You can come, too.
-Scott and I were talking -- we
have parents who were teachers.
Your mom was a teacher as well.
Kindergarten?
-Kindergarten teacher.
-And how does she feel?
Obviously, she must --
[ Applause ]
Yes, let's give it up
for all the teachers.
You obviously are writing
the show
based on experiences
you've had in school.
Does she respond to it?
Does she like what she sees?
-She loves it.
She -- my mom is very...
Me being her daughter
doesn't matter.
=She just enjoys the show,
and I think that's
the most positive
thing that I could
get out of it.
She told me last week,
she's like,
"I'll watch this even
if you weren't on it."
And I was like,
"I don't know how I feel about
that," but she's enjoying it.
There's some things that she
feels are directly taken
from her life, and they are --
like an episode
where the teacher,
Barbara Howard, doesn't remember
the student at all.
That's completely my mom.
People come up to her all the
time, and she just pretends.
She's so nice
and so sweet about it.
And then afterwards, she's like,
"I don't know who that boy was."
[ Laughter ]
-Do you think she's convincing
to the boy in question?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
If you saw your teacher walking
down the street and you went,
"Hey, Ms. Smith, Ms. Smith!"
And you believe
she remembers you, right?
Like she hasn't had seven Seths
since you've been in her class.
But, yeah, I mean,
she makes them believe it.
She sells it.
-So you obviously
are in show business,
but you've gone back to your
mom's career of education.
But when you were in college...
-Yeah.
-...you hosted a talk show.
-I did.
-Now, was this on like
access television?
-It was on Facebook.
-Okay, it was on Facebook.
-It was when Facebook
had just gotten videos,
so it wasn't what it is now.
It was pure.
It was like when you had to have
a college email address
to use it, and it was called
"The Rant."
And I just ranted about things
that happened on my campus.
-Okay.
-And I had obscure guests.
-Who were some of your guests?
-One of the guests
was just my friend.
That's it.
[ Laughter ]
Another guest was this guy, Tim.
He was on because all
the Black girls thought he was
the hottest White guy on campus,
so that qualified him
being able to be
a guest on the show.
-And then, were the questions
about, "What is it about you,
that you think you're the
hottest White guy on campus?"
-No, and unlike you --
which is why I don't have
this kind of a show --
I just accosted him
with my own thoughts.
And I don't think
I really asked him much.
-Oh, you had a talk-at show.
-Yeah, I did.
I did, I did, I did.
-Philly, obviously,
is your home,
and Philly is kind of having
having a moment, right?
-Yes, Philly is having a moment.
They have "Abbott Elementary."
They have "Bel-Air."
We got James Harden.
-You got James Harden.
-We got James Harden.
-James harden wanted --
-Why y'all hatin'?
Y'all don't...
[ Laughter ]
-James Harden was walking
down the street.
He saw a beautiful woman
in garbage and he was like,
"I gotta get out there."
[ Laughter ]
He was like,
"I gotta force a trade."
-Gotta go, too.
Yeah, no, we're having a moment.
It's really nice. I'm happy.
-And it must be nice.
Are people -- do you feel the
love from your home city?
-I feel it.
I feel it all the time.
It's nice to go back home.
And I was just back there,
and I was just going
to the liquor store
to get -- get some liquor.
[ Laughter ]
That's what you get there,
and someone yelled at me,
"Ain't you Janine?"
And I was like, "I am."
And they were like, "Yeah, girl.
You need to dump
that boyfriend."
And I was like, "Okay."
Most people in Philly
just think the show is real.
Yeah, so...
[ Laughter ]
-Well, if they thought you were
an actor, they'd be like,
"Why are you buying
your own liquor?"
-Yeah, it's very confusing
for them, the kids.
Everybody's confused
about what's going on.
-Alright. So, Scott is playing
a very believable --
in this new horror film --
adult film star.
-Yeah.
-You had an early VO'er --
-Wait, wait, what?
Now, where's this going?
-Just watch.
-I know.
-Listen again.
Well, you won't believe how
good I am at transition.
[ Laughter ]
You had a VO audition.
-I did.
-Voiceover, sorry.
For the biz -- "VO,"
voice actor.
-Come on, Seth.
-So, this is early
in your career.
-You can't even call
it my career, at that point?
-Okay, got it.
-But I did.
What's this come on, NBC?
My mom's not gonna -- I'll tell
her not to watch this show.
But basically, the --
[ Laughter ]
-Can you just tell her
to watch the first part?
-Yeah, I know.
-I'd love her to get
a little face time.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, she likes the monologues.
And then, I'll just tell her
the rest of it's canceled.
That's what I tell her
when I don't want her
to watch something.
I'm like,
"They canceled it, Mom."
So, I needed some money,
because I was really broke,
and I saw an opportunity
on Craigslist
for some voiceover work.
And I was like, "I want to be
in cartoons one day.
I'd love to do that."
So I click the link
and it's like,
"Play a character for someone
to call you up
and have a good time."
And I was like,
"That sounds fun."
-"Have a good time."
[ Laughter ]
-Cool, I'm gonna be a moose
with balloons for antlers.
-Yep.
-They're like, "No."
-And they sent me my name,
and my name was Crystal.
[ Laughter ]
And they sent me a picture of
who I was supposed to look like.
I don't know if people know
who Buffie the Body is,
but that's who she --
You know Buffie the Body.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-Very white audience,
but she's a very famous vixen.
She is really beautiful,
and they sent me a picture
of basically her,
and I had to, like,
pretend to be her on the
phone for people that called.
-Yeah.
-And it was really gross.
I couldn't get through it,
but they did tell the truth.
They said, "You will get paid
a dollar a minute,"
and I made $3 that day.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I made $3.
-You know what?
When people are up front,
you have to give them
respect for that.
Alright, well, congratulations
on season 2.
-Thank you.
-I hope, over dinner tonight,
Scott talks his way into it.
-Yeah.
-He's Kid Cudi.
It's pretty easy.
I don't know why he's like --
Tyler was like, "This guy wants
to be on the show."
I was like, "Yeah, he can."
[ Laughter ]
-You guys,
that's Quinta Brunson.
"Abbott Elementary" airs
Tuesday nights on ABC.
Kid Cudi over there.
We'll be right back.